Now let's work on finding
the intersection of planes.
Let's start by assuming we have
two planes Ax + By + Cz = k1 and
Dx + Ey + Fz = k2,
where the normal vectors A,
B, C and D, E, F aren't parallel.
Given two non-parallel planes,
I claim their intersection will be
a line instead of a single point.
>From the picture,
this may seem intuitive but
how can we show this fact
algebraically in all cases?
Let's use a tool from the previous
lesson, the cross product.
Consider the cross product of these
two normal vectors n1 and n2.
Since the two normal
vectors are not parallel
their cross product will not be zero.
Also remember that n1 cross n2 will
be orthogonal to both n1 and n2.
Let's pick an arbitrary point in
the intersection of the two planes and
call it x0.
If x is any other point
in the intersection,
then let's call d sub x,
the vector from x0 to x.
Since x0 and x are both in the first
plane, the vector connecting them,
d sub x, will be orthogonal to the
normal vector to the first plane, n1.
By similar reasoning since x0 and
x are both in plane two,
the vector connecting them
dx will be orthogonal to n2.
Since dx is orthogonal to both n1 and
n2 and since we're in three dimensions,
dx must be parallel to
the cross product of n1 and n2.
Since dx is parallel to n1 cross n2
no matter what x we picked, that means
the intersection of these two planes
has to be a line that is
parallel to n1 cross n2.
So what are the consequences of this?
Well if we have a system of two linear
equations in three dimensions, then
the set of point satisfying the system,
could form a line's worth of solutions,
if the equations define two
planes that are not parallel.
No solutions, if the equations
define different parallel planes, or
a whole plane's worth of solutions, if
the two equations define the same plane.
However, if we introduce
a third equation to our system,
then we could have another possibility.
The common intersection of the three
planes could be a single point.
Or it could be a line,
a plane, or nothing at all.
There are a few important
observations we should make here.
Recall that one equation in two
variables defines a line or
a one dimensional linear object.
A single equation in three
dimensional space defines a plane,
which is a two
dimensional linear object.
In general a single equation
in some number of variables,
will define a linear object
that has a number of dimensions
one less than the number of variables.
However we need to be careful to
distinguish between an equation
say in two variables,
and an equation in,
say, three variables, where one of
the variables has a coefficient of 0.
In the former case,
the equation defines a line in 2D.
But in the latter case the equation
defines a plane in 3D.
Being aware of the context of your
problem will help you avoid this error.
Another observation is that
the coefficients of the variables
in a linear equation
give the coordinates for
a normal vector to the linear
object it defines.
So for the line Ax + By = k we
obtain the normal vector AB and
for the plane Ax + By + Cz = k,
we have a normal vector of ABC.
This trend will continue as we
move into higher dimensions.
And again, this is why the normal vector
is a useful piece of information for
defining a linear object.
One last observation is that we need
at least two lines in two variables
to obtain a unique
intersection of lines.
And we need at least three planes
in three dimensional space or
three variables to obtain a unique
intersection of the planes.
This observation will generalize as we
progress into higher dimensions, and
in a little bit we'll see
an algebraic reason why it holds.